how true is the caveman stereotype where
and how did our early ancestors live
if we look to our closest living
relatives gorillas and chimpanzees
gorillas tend to live in kin groups of
perhaps a dozen individuals while
chimpanzees form in groups of as many as
100 or more
Guerrilla territories might Encompass
about 15 square kilometers while
chimpanzees tend to average closer to 40
square kilometers
chimpanzee home range sizes are
especially flexible and depend on such
factors as how many group members there
are and what the surrounding landscape
is like as well as who lives nearby
most chimpanzee foraging takes place in
a core area surrounded by a periphery
and males are extremely territorial
violent conflict can occur near the
borders of these territories
each night chimpanzees painstakingly
build new nests from freshly gathered
leaves and twigs to sleep in
chimps use a variety of plant species to
construct their nests some of which have
medicinal properties
so perhaps not coincidentally these
nests contain significantly less
bacteria than does the bed of an average
person
it appears our ancestors prepared for
sleep in a somewhat similar fashion
at border cave in South Africa evidence
of bedding has been recovered in
archaeological layers dating as far back
as 227 000 to 183 000 years ago
these beds consisted of Blades of grass
and camphor leaves which have
insecticidal properties
many deep free and natural bug sprays on
the market today include camphor as an
ingredient
what's more the beds appear to have been
constructed on top of and mixed with Ash
Remnant layers of previous bedding which
probably doubled as another protective
element from insects and provided some
insulation
the early bedding was identified through
a number of sophisticated methods
including soil micromorphology which
I'll discuss in a moment and a technique
called phytolith analysis
vitalyths are tiny microscopic
silica-based particles left behind by
the decay of plants
think of them as the fossils of
individual plant cells
while a plant is living silica helps
provide rigidity within the structure of
the plant as it's absorbed
the silica forms different shapes
depending on whether it's located in the
leaf or the stem
an expert can generally identify a
phytolith as coming from a blade of
grass versus the leaf of a tree although
this isn't true for all plants
what's more vitalists can tell us
whether plant material was burned or not
based on whether the fossilized cells
appear clear or dark under the
microscope
a team led by South African
archaeologist Lynn Wadley found that bed
making also occurred around 77 000 years
ago at sabudu Cave in South Africa
wadley's team is the same one that
discovered the betting at border cave
the beds at sabudu included remnants of
sedges rushes grasses and camphor Bush
wadley's team used phytolith and
micromorphology Analysis paired with an
experiment in which they constructed
beds out of dried sedges burned and
compressed the beds and then repeated
the process before burying their
creation
later they excavated and analyzed the
remains to compare with the original
archaeological material
they found that the phytolith remains
and resulting soil micromorphology were
similar to that found in the
archaeological sample so what does
micromorphology entail
it's another technique in our
archaeological toolkit and as its name
suggests another method that involves
staring down the eyepiece of a
microscope
geo-archaeologists concentrate on the
geological aspects of archeology
one of the more specialized approaches
is micromorphological analysis
it begins in a relatively
unsophisticated way
stratigraphic sections that is the
exposed vertical surface of an
excavation trench that shows the layers
of sediment as they were originally
deposited
are sampled by removing rectangular
blocks that preserve the Integrity of
the layers
normally you'd Target an area that is
visibly of Interest such as the corner
of an ancient house floor or ash from a
fire
once the block has been removed it's
taken to a lab where it's impregnated
with resin and left to cure for some
time as the resin dries
then several slabs are cut into thin
sections which are polished and mounted
for microscopy
I learned this technique as a master
student at Cambridge and found it
fascinating
under the microscope you can see fine
layers of sight formation not visible to
the naked eye
and the arrangement of particles can
tell you about things like trampling and
redeposition
in the case of the beds at sabudu and
Border caves that's exactly what
researchers saw
evidence of routine burning the ash
trampled down and fresh beds made
lithics were also recovered in the bed
areas leading archaeologists to suggest
that they were likely seating areas for
other activities too like the
manufacture of stone tools in the cave
can you imagine living in a cave most
caves are uninvitingly dark dank and
quite frankly if something else already
lives there dangerous
so why do we find so much evidence of
human activity in caves
for the most part people in the past
were never really cavemen dwelling
inside a cave and using it as we think
of a home today
most archaeological evidence of human
activity in and around caves is at their
entrance or mouth
caves consist of three main parts the
entrance a Twilight Zone and a dark Zone
sometimes we find cave art and human
remains in the Twilight zones and even
the dark zones but it's likely that
these areas were off limits for regular
use and they might have even had sacred
connotations
as groups use the entrance area of a
cave activities were probably also
taking place outside
these might not be as well preserved as
contexts inside the cave
we see this bias in the overall
archaeological record
it's far more likely that the shelter
caves provided to people also protected
what was left behind
in contrast open air sites exposed to
the elements might not have left traces
of human activity
this creates a bias in the
archaeological record towards cave sites
even though people were spending plenty
of time in the daylight
without doubt humans made camp in a
variety of environments including out in
the open
we do have evidence although it's scarce
of lithic scatters hearths and Bone
remains from throughout the Paleolithic
period
but among the first rules of survival is
to construct shelter
so where is the evidence for that
most camps were probably ephemeral
occupied for short periods of time and
constructed of organic materials like
wood that did not preserve
the distribution of Natural Resources
played a role in where people chose to
live and when and how far to move
whether a cave or structure these
Horrors and homes represent safety
security and permanence in the landscape
for the first time and served as a
crucial hub for food preparation and
Tool making
so what then is our earliest evidence
for built structures
this too comes mostly from caves
at the cave site of how fataya in Libya
a post hole in a layer dating to between
thirty thousand to forty thousand years
ago attests to deliberate Construction
post holes are distinctive
archaeological features
they occur from a hole being dug a cut
to place a piece of wood the post into
the ground the Earth is then stabilized
with fill back around the wood
the wood eventually leaves a ring of Ash
if burned or organic material if left to
rot
so far the very earliest evidence for
post holes dates to 100 000 years ago
three post holes were found at the
Zambian site of Mumbai cave
their location seemed to have been for a
wall interpreted as a Windbreak
protecting a semi-circular deposition of
bone lithics and Ash
some argue that the lack of evidence for
structures at open air sites where
archaeological evidence does exist for
lithics bones and Fire
means that people didn't bother to build
any shelter at all
but horse herders in the Mongolian step
for example set up Yurts that didn't
require post holes or digging
and after returning to such a site a
year later you might not see any
evidence that people had been there at
all
indeed ethno-archeology might help
bridge the gap between what we expect to
find at an ephemeral camp and what we do
actually find
one of my favorite papers on this
subject is by the Greek archaeologist
Nina galanidu who reviewed the use of
space by modern foragers at caves and
rock shelters in different environments
gallinudu found that people use space in
different ways with separate activity
areas refuse disposal areas and hearth
but that these patterns are related more
to the cultural background of a group
and the way that people relate to the
space
than to any physical constraints of the
this idea is essential to keep in mind
when we interpret how ancient peoples
perceive their surroundings and their
need for shelter and Fire
it may be that the occurrence of fire
and the existence of hearts are better
proxies for identifying human occupation
the earliest documented occurrence of
human-controlled fire is hotly debated
but could have been as early as 1.5
million years ago
it's important to separate opportunistic
use of fire from the routine of making
it
we might find evidence of fire use
through burning but archaeological
hearths are the product of fires that
were started controlled and burned at
certain temperatures and occurred in the
same spot more than once
some of the earliest evidence for the
use of fires from Africa when Homo
erectus roamed the land
but it is inconclusive as to the extent
that it was routinely used and whether
or not humans created it as opposed to
taking advantage of existing fires such
as those caused by lightning strikes
some of the best evidence for
human-controlled fire comes from
wonderwork cave in South Africa reaching
back a million years ago
contemporary analysis applying
micromorphology and a technique called
ftir shows that plant material and
animal bones were once burned there
outside of Africa the gesherbeno Yakov
site in Israel yields related evidence
from as early as 790 000 years ago that
Flint tools were burnt in order to
harden them
not until about 400 000 years ago does
the evidence seem to support routine
control over and use of fire represented
by examples of burnt material and Ash
layers
some of the best early evidence for the
repeated and deliberate use of hards in
Europe comes from the Baltimore cave
site in Spain
14 hearths each made in a rough circular
shape on the ground were analyzed macro
and microscopically and found to date
back 228 000 years with an error range
of about 50 000 years
this might sound like a lot but it's
important to keep in mind that the
further back in time we go the less
precise Our dating methods are
in this instance researchers dated snail
shells in the archaeological layer
containing the hearts
they used a method called amino acid
rasamization which has been growing in
popularity yet still remains somewhat
controversial
amino acid rasamization Works like this
our DNA tells our bodies which amino
acids to produce
these combine to form proteins
the molecular structure of amino acids
can exist in one of two possible forms L
and D which are mirror images of one
another
in living organisms amino acids exist
for the most part in their L form
as in other dating methods an event
occurs to start the clock ticking
in radiocarbon and amino acid dating
it's the death of the individual
once an individual dies the amino acids
in the body begin to shift from L to D
but not all at the same time
we measure the ratio of L to D forms to
estimate how long it's been since death
one problem is that unlike radiocarbon
which decays at a constant rate no
matter what the Decay rate here can be
influenced by a number of external and
internal factors including the acidity
of the surrounding sediment humidity and
temperature basically any variable that
affects the overall preservation of the
material
in our example the snails in the layer
with fire might have been dead for quite
a while before the layer was buried
but not more than 50 000 years which
encompasses the range of error for this
date
still amino acid rasamization is useful
only in certain circumstances and the
problem of calculating the Decay rate is
a big one
it's something I expect to be refined in
the future as the technique is applied
more widely
so if evidence for hearths and homes is
relatively scarce throughout most of
human history when do we start to see it
flourish
it's not until later in the upper
Paleolithic period around fifteen
thousand years ago when evidence for
more significant built structures
appears though nothing yet that we might
refer to as a village
the meserix site in Ukraine is notable
because it yielded one of our best
examples of early musical instruments a
mammoth skull painted with ocher and
other bones apparently used to beat it
like a drum
but the site is also remarkable because
of another way these Mammoth bones were
used to build houses
in 1965 a local farmer discovered the
lower portion of a mammoth jaw a
mandible and reported his find
subsequent excavation revealed four
large circular dwellings the largest
measuring 8 meters or around 26 feet in
diameter
it was entirely constructed from Mammoth
bones
in at least one of the structures
mandibles were used to create the
foundational first layer with flatter
bones such as the scapula used higher up
in the structure
it's likely there was perhaps a wooden
frame but wood was too scarce on the
Frozen landscape at the time to be used
for the entire structure
animal skins probably helped insulate
the bone structure from the elements
at the time these houses were built
fifteen thousand years ago the world was
in the throes of the end of the last ice
age
though the peak had passed conditions in
Ukraine would have still been
tundra-like at the time
this feat of early engineering is all
the more impressive when you consider
the weight of the bones
each structure used about 20 tons of
bone and the remains of an estimated 95
mammoths
this is not the only archaeological site
with evidence for mammoth bone houses
but it's also important for what it
implies about the overall settlement
pattern
here the world's earliest map was
inscribed on a piece of ivory
it represents a schematic of the local
area at the Confluence of two
tributaries of the Nipa River
other mammoth bone sites were also found
along this River Valley situated on Old
Terraces with strategic views
overlooking what likely were fertile
hunting grounds below
yet another example of an early built
settlement comes from the Mesolithic
site of lipenskivir in Serbia along the
iron gates Gorge of the Danube River
caves near the site bear evidence of use
during the last ice age at least twenty
thousand years ago
but not until well after the world began
to warm did lipensky Veer coalesce about
9 500 years ago
one reason this site is fascinating is
for what it shows us about how modern
scientific techniques can inform us of
the past at amazing levels of detail
sometimes the story of History changes
completely
lipensky Veer was first discovered in
1960 and began to be excavated in 1965.
so radiocarbon dating existed but it was
rudimentary and other more refined
methods of excavation were not yet
deregur
over a period of about five years
amazing finds emerged at the site
including enigmatic fish sculptures
stone-lined hars trapezoidal structures
with hard lime plaster floors which were
interpreted as both houses and shrines
and a necropolis
it was thought that this site
represented an early Advanced
agricultural population
the zoo archaeologist sandor bakani
published a paper in the journal science
claiming that the site was an example of
local animal domestication occurring
independently from what was happening in
the near East
early radio carbon dates seem to support
the argument
but some questioned the accuracy of the
claims
unfortunately what was excavated from
the site was moved nearly wholesale and
reconstructed at another location in
1970 when a hydroelectric Dam flooded
the iron gates inundating lipensky vir
and many other archaeological sites
whose stories as a result will never be
known
still advancements in radiocarbon dating
technology particularly the Advent of
accelerator Mass spectrometry which
allows for more precise dates
enabled researchers to return to the
question of the dates for lipensky Veer
in the late 1990s and early 2000s
animal bones and human remains from the
site were re-evaluated using improved
radiocarbon methods
and the dates did not agree with each
other
humans appeared to have lived there
earlier in time than some of the animals
from the same layers
what would cause this discrepancy
researchers carried out stable isotope
analysis on the human and animal remains
and found that these people in addition
to hunting and Gathering ate a lot of
fish
and this had caused a big problem for
the radiocarbon dating
let me explain
as the Danube flowed across ancient
Limestone old carbon 14 sequestered in
the Rock dissolved and entered the
tissues of living fish alongside the
carbon-14 atoms of the time
people eat these fish ingesting old and
new carbon
the stable isotope analysis revealed
this making it necessary to calibrate
the freshwater Reservoir effect by
calculating the offset between fish
eating humans and non-fish eating
animals
ultimately they reach the conclusion
that the site was a few thousand years
more recent than originally argued and
not a unique instance of the early
Neolithic period in Europe the earliest
layers at the site were reassigned to
the Mesolithic period prior to farming
still these Mesolithic layers contain
intriguing evidence for lined hearts and
the emergence of built structures prior
to the arrival of domestic animals from
further south
early Holocene hunter gatherer Fishers
were spending extended periods of time
in one place and constructing more
permanent places to sleep at night
radiocarbon dating has been one of the
best tools in archeology for
synthesizing the grand Narrative of our
shared past
and it's become quite the trend in
archeology to return to existing
archaeological sites and re-date them to
refine our understanding
this helps us get at what was happening
when at a particular site and it helps
us to comprehend change over greater
temporal and spatial scales
for instance One Way archaeologists try
to reconstruct the nature and extent of
human settlement patterns through time
is mapping and modeling with radiocarbon
dates
now the radiocarbon date record is for
the most part only as good as the
excavated sites
so blank spots on the map might
represent not a lack of settlement but
instead a lack of research
also many radiocarbon dates generated
before the Advent of AMS instrumentation
provided erroneously broad date ranges
artificially lengthening estimated
periods of occupation
and some well-known sites don't have
good radiocarbon dates just lithic
chronologies
other problems arise when we consider
material that was dated while people
still thought that it was okay to smoke
cigarettes during an excavation
introducing contamination from younger
carbon
so you might be able to amass 1000
radiocarbon dates from a given region
but by the time you clean your data set
only 200 of them might be usable
to analyze a period of let's say ten
thousand years that's not very many data
points
my colleague Mark Van Der Linden and I
ran into some of these issues when we
try to evaluate the environmental and
settlement history of the Balkans from
the end of the last ice age through to
the transition to the Neolithic period
and the arrival of agriculture
we were able to argue that the overall
population increased just prior to the
introduction of domestic plants and
animals likely due to favorable
environmental conditions at around 8 200
years ago
others have applied radiocarbon date
distribution modeling across Europe and
North America to track the spread of
populations and increases in population
density
the drive to a mass and synthesized
radiocarbon dates and other types of
archaeological evidence in an effort to
model human settlement has led to the
growth of numerous large collaborative
data sets in archeology
in this way we will continue to advance
our understanding of the development of
human society as we move forward in our
study of the past
[Music]